laut nasa werden wir in den nächsten
jahren aliens finden und die nasa will
die erste weltraumorganisation sein der
das gelingt damit sie dabei erfolgreich
ist hat sie jetzt eine neue organisation
gegründet um schneller erfolgreich zu
werden
sie haben jetzt das center for life
depeschen seien cl die es auf deutsch
das zentrum für die erkennung von leben
ins leben rufen was die nasa damit
vorhat viel zum science fiction hier
gibt es täglich faszinierendes heinz
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst er nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen die nasa scheint sich immer
sicher zu sein dass wir tatsächlich
schon bald auf außerirdisches leben
stoßen werden um das zu beschleunigen
hat sie jetzt das center for life
detektion science tlds gegründet dabei
soll das center alle möglichen
prinzipien abklopfen und wissenschaftler
und wissenschaftlerinnen nicht nur der
nasa an der suche beteiligen im rahmen
des centers for life detection science
sollen forschungsteam der georgetown
university und der georgia tech
university mit der nasa kooperieren und
so die suche auf eine breitere basis
gestellt werden werden jetzt also aliens
schneller gefunden center jeff tory
hüller
wir haben jetzt die wissenschaftliche
und technische expertise um diese
tiefgreifende frage mit der klarheit
wissenschaftlicher beweise anzugehen und
wir haben eine großartige gemeinschaft
von wissenschaftlern die bereit für
diese große herausforderung sind das
hört sich nach einem jahren dabei setzt
die neue institution auf ein sehr
breites verständnis von außerirdischen
leben
die suche nach leben jenseits der erde
kann kein einheitlicher ansatz sein so
höhler sprich leben kann nach auffassung
von höherer ganz anders an als wie wir
es kennen und selbst hier auf der erde
gibt es ja immer wieder überraschungen
einzeller die direkt an heißen quellen
bei 80 grad celsius von deren chemische
energie leben und einen schwefel
stoffwechsel haben
sauerstoff ist für sie giftig oder ein
lebewesen das quadratkilometer groß ist
der pilz der gattung hallimasch im
nordamerikanischen oregon erstreckt sich
über neun quadratkilometer und ist
schätzungsweise 2400 jahre alt also
schon hier auf der erde gibt es extrem
außergewöhnliches leben wie könnte es
also erst auf exoplaneten oder den mond
nieren und
sonnen system existieren wo die
bedingungen ganz anders sind wie zum
beispiel auf dem saturnmond enceladus
deshalb definiert sarah stewart von der
georgetown university das ziel der neuen
organisation so das leben so zu erkennen
wie wir es nicht kennen
um das zu erreichen müssen laut oehler
so vorgegangen werden um den besten
erfolg zu erzielen müssen wir werkzeuge
und strategien entwickeln die darauf
ausgelegt sind das leben unter den
einzigartigen bedingungen anderer welten
zu erkennen die sich nicht nur von der
erde sondern auch voneinander
unterscheiden
deshalb will sich das team jetzt auf die
ozeane der monde mit indizien für leben
in unserem sonnensystem und den antiken
maß konzentrieren bei mars geht es also
um lebensformen die dort vor millionen
jahren existiert haben könnten als er
sogar so lebensfreundlich wie die erde
gewesen sein könnte aber auch die suche
nach leben auf exoplaneten soll weiter
vorangetrieben werden dafür wurde ein
online portal geschaffen damit auch
außenstehende wissenschaftler und
wissenschaftlerinnen daten des seti
projektes auswerten können hier werden
ja unendlich viele daten aus den
signalen des weltraums gefiltert um
darin tatsächliche lebenszeichen zu
finden da würde es ja extrem spannend ob
künstliche intelligenz jetzt nicht viel
schneller auf intelligente signale in
den unmengen an daten stoßen wird und
vielleicht ein kleines forschungsteam
außerhalb der nasa dafür den besseren
algorithmus entwickelt der erste kontakt
könnte also schneller stattfinden als
wir denken wie er aussieht dass er vater
im video von doktor watson hier klicken
ein extrem spannendes video also deshalb
folgendes machen draufklicken ansehen
und abonnieren bis dann bleibt